I I have to tell you a couple things my
real question isn't who who throws a
dildo at somebody my real question is
who brings one to the show
[Applause]
do you know what I'm saying like I guess
if you got it and you're looking for
them to throw that makes sense to me but
who's like oh I forgot my dildo you know
what I mean like
I really gotta check what kind of
advertising I'm putting out
[Applause]
because if she was like I can't forget
my tiny little dildo tonight
I'm not gonna lie to you the balls
[Applause]
for real they look like my dog's nuts
before we got them cut
[Applause]
yo I wish it was one of those things
that just never stopped doing this
laughs
[Applause]
magic two balls tell me if it's true uh
yo for real it looks like an Olympic
High Dive board just
[Applause]
but like
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just the way it's shaped it looks
like a real Curious dick like
[Applause]
it's looking for answers like
[Applause]
the whole show I'm telling you right now
I could Drew this all [ __ ] night are
you kidding
ah damn oh my God all right yeah all
right
[Music]
that's how big her titties were they
made that noise through the air